also so ein bisschen ist mein Thema die
Steuer der Staat wird mehr und mehr zum
Verschiebebahnhof des Geldes der Bürger
ja wo man hinguckt wollen sie Steuern
erhöhen Steuer erniedrigen und das Geld
von rechts nach links schieben für CO2
und sonstiges und ich
der eine proklamiert großartig 12 Euro
aber die unser Staat hat so viel Geld
und was mich auch extrem stört dass wir
das zweitgrößte Parlament auf der Welt
haben nur die Chinesen sind größer ja
und es verschlingt also auch ein enormen
Batzen vom Geld und die Renten für
unsere ganzen Beamten und Politiker es
gehört jemand an die Spitze diese
Staates der ausgewiesener Finanzexperte
ist und der ist auf keinen Fall in
meinem Ranking wie heißt der Olaf Scholz
ja da kann ich also nicht unterschreiben
und ich glaube ich habe ich bin eine
kleine mode-unternehmerin habe in meinem
Leben als modeunternehmerin vielleicht
100 Millionen Umsatz gemacht und dass
ich da alles in den Laden geschaufelt
habe vom Finanzamt das hätte ich auch
gern für mich und ich bin dafür dass der
der den Kuchen backt oder Schnitzel brät
den Hauptteil vom Gewinn hat und nicht
der Staat ging gar nicht wissen wie man
das sorgsam damit umgeht ja denn wenn du
immer nur zwischen steuertöpfen hin und
her schon liest das heißt ja nicht dass
du was erwirtschaftest wie unser eins
wie jeder einzelne Bürger wie jeder
Angestellte wie jeder Mitarbeiter ich
zahl ich weiß es die höchsten
Stundenlöhne in meiner Firma zwischen 25
und 40 Euro für Stylistinnen und so
weiter und ich finde denen gehört noch
mehr dass der der arbeitet wieder
wesentlich mehr Motivation hat dir
bisher hat das war ein tolles Plädoyer
würde ich zu 100% unterstützen ich
befürchte nur mit Blick auf die nächsten
vier Jahre
würde ich auch mindestens nicht besser
vielleicht sogar eher schlecht aber ich
habe einen Punkt den gemacht haben der
ist absolut richtig und das ist immer
die Frage was passiert eigentlich mit
Menschen die viel arbeiten und damit
meine ich gar nicht denjenigen der
Manager ist und Millionen verdient
sondern damit meine Familie Unternehmer
wie sie damit meine ich aber auch
Angestellte das kann auch eine Putzfrau
sein eine Verkäuferin ganz genau und die
Frage ist ja ist unser Steuersystem
eigentlich gerecht wir stellen ja fest
je mehr man arbeitet und je mehr man
verdient umso höher wird der Steuersatz
eigentlich müsste es genau umgekehrt
sein der Anreiz zu arbeiten der muss ja
größer werden also zu sagen ich arbeite
noch eine Stunde mehr und noch eine
Stunde und noch eine Stunde und deswegen
müsste eigentlich der Steuersatz sinken
bis jetzt je mehr man arbeitet und nicht
steigen also wir haben ein falsches
Steuersystem ein Steuersystem das
leistungsfeindlich ist absolut in der
Schweiz ist es doch so habe ich letztens
gelesen also das ist bestimmte Kantone
gibt die sich darauf geeinigt haben den
Steuersatz zu erniedrigen wenn man ab
ein also wenn man gewissen Umsatz
erzielt also ich muss auch sagen ich
finde das Steuer Thema
lästig und leidig und ich befürchte auch
dass es Steuererhöhungen geben wird was
ich immer besonders was mir besonders in
den ganzen Debatten fehlt ist dass wir
immer über noch mehr Steuern sprechen um
es denjenigen zu geben die es nötig
haben um den Sozialstaat noch weiter
anzufüttern ich würde eher sagen lasst
doch den Menschen am Ende des Monats
mehr Geld also der Staat sollte sich da
ein bisschen mal zurückhalten weil im
Grunde ist ja der Staat derjenige der so
viel sage ich mal aus dem Topf raus
nimmt und nicht nicht unbedingt der also
nicht die Lebensmittelpreise der Staat
ist in der verteilermafia ja derzeit
holt sich her wo er gerade lustig ist ja
zum Beispiel bei mir und mein
Mitarbeitern bei meinen Angestellten zum
Beispiel wenn einer 12 Euro in der
Stunde bekommt wer ich dafür der muss
überhaupt keine Steuern zahlen ja weil
konsumieren ich zeige total gerne
Steuern muss ich sagen ich bin stolz auf
meine Steuern die ich zahle ich würde
aber eine Erwartung an den Start haben
nämlich dass er das Geld richtig ausgeht
und da ist ja aber das ist für mich der
Hauptpunkt ich mich langweilen diese
Debatten ob der Steuersatz hierbei so
und so viel Prozent und in der bei der
nächsten Wahl geht es wieder gibt es
wieder ein steuerwahlkampf und man weiß
vorher schon das wird sowieso nichts
davon eingehalten wir haben seit 16
Jahren Merkel haben wir keine einzige
Steuerreform erlebt wir können das hier
ad acta legen unser Steuersystem ist so
kompliziert es wird niemals reformiert
werden aber was erreicht werden könnte
das Geld dass der Staat einnimmt
ordentlich auszugeben und wenn ich sehe
dass meine Steuern die ich total gerne
zahle hier in Berlin für solche Schulen
verwendet werden da kommen ja die Tränen
da kommen mir die Tränen in den Augen
zum Teil es wird verbrannt deshalb ist
es besser man lässt bei den Leuten
dieser Wirtschaften ja ich werde auch
nicht so defizistisch also ich glaube
schon dass es ab und zu mal auch einer
Steuerreform Bedarf wir haben ja gesehen
vor Corona sind ja die Steuereinnahmen
sukzessive über Jahre auf immer neue
Rekordhöhen gestiegen hängt natürlich
auch in unserem tarifzusammenhängen
zusammen mit der sehr gut laufenden
Konjunktur von daher glaube ich hat der
Staat sich angewöhnt und die Politiker
die Regierungen das war immer mehr da
ist sprudelte quasi ohne dass man
eigentlich mehr Olaf Scholz gesammelt
gesammelt gesammelt gesammelt
Finanzminister zu enden der die meisten
Schulden gemacht hat von allen ja das
war natürlich dann in der Corona Krise
klar aber ich glaube also da würde ich
mir wünschen durchaus das Geld was da
genommen wird nicht per se immer einfach
zu nehmen also der Punkt den sie auch
gemacht haben glaube ich absolut richtig
also wir oder auch was Sie gesagt haben
dieser verteilbahnhof den es gibt das
ist ja ein nehmen und man sagt immer und
man gibt es anderen Leuten am Ende diese
das Thema auch Kita frei also
gebührenfreie Kitas beispielsweise ist
auch ein Verschiebebahnhof der Stadt
findet man muss immer wissen wenn auch
Politiker sich hinstellen und sagen
jetzt ist etwas kostenlos es ist nie
etwas kostenlos ist zahlen dann nur
andere im Zweifel Sie oder Ihre
Mitarbeiter die Mitarbeiter sie das ist
ja der Punkt ich halte einfach für Sinn
dass das Geld bei dem bleibt der die
Leistung der verbringt und das ist nicht
der Staat und das auch die die ganzen
Angestellten die unteren Chargen wenn
die extrem entlastet werden ja wenn der
Staat weniger Geld hat dann kann er
seine
zusammengemorgsten Leistungen halt nicht
mehr erbringen aber wenn die private
Hand des Geld hat dann wird vieles
besser als meine Meinung gar nicht so
weit auseinander ich würde nur vom Staat
viel mehr Leistung einfordern aber ich
würde gerne dass der seine Leistung
einfach verbringen ich sichere
Arbeitsplätze der hat noch nie einen
geschaffen dann kann auch keinen sichern
ich sicher seit 30 Jahren in Dutzend
Arbeitsplätzen ehrlich gesagt das ist
jetzt gar nicht persönlich gemeint aber
diejenigen gibt ja auch viele Millionäre
auf die Nerven die sagen ja ich würde
gerne mehr Steuern zahlen es gibt
interessanterweise beim
Bundesfinanzministerium eine Kontonummer
genau für jene die meinen die Zahlen zu
viele Steuern da gehen im Jahr zu wenig
Steuern würden gerne mehr Zahlen gibt
genug Unternehmer die hat ja immer
wieder auch Musiker die sagen wir müssen
mehr Steuern zahlen wir zahlen zu wenig
enttäuschen
sie können ja aber mal gucken was da
eingeht im Jahr da gehen zum Teil etwas
mehr als 10.000 Euro im Jahr ein
bedeutet all diejenigen die sich immer
hinstellen und sagen ich zahl zu wenig
Steuern ich möchte mehr Zeit die ducken
sich aber schön Weg das ist eine
Doppelmoral die finde ich echt
gefährlich die ist auch unehrlich und
die ist dieser Menschen gar nicht würdig
also das sind reine Lippenbekenntnisse
ich will mich jetzt hier nicht
hinstellen als große Mutter Teresa aber
ich habe ein ich habe ein großes Herz
und nicht unterstützt gern die Leute
direkt die was brauchen ja die ihr in
Not sind ich mache da einiges es darf
man gar nicht sagen weil ich das auch
noch versteuern muss ja was ich da so
mache unter dem Tisch ab ja wenn ich
jemand Klamotten schenkt der keine hat
der der dies und das dann da muss ich da
zehn Seiten Formular für ausfüllen und
lauter so ein Quatsch es wird einem
richtig leicht gemacht
so ein bisschen guten
ehemalige Mitarbeiter den sie auch nicht
gerade so gut geht aufgrundwissen auch
immer ja einladen ja dann dann muss ich
sozusagen die auch privat bezahlen und
darf das nicht als Spende proklamieren
aber so ist das Leben und da weiß man
sich auch zu helfen lange Rede gar
keinen Sinn aber ich hoffe und wie man
so sieht es es gibt schon Möglichkeiten
in aus krassen Strukturen
herauszuwachsen das war bei Corona so da
ist einiges ja wenn es mal ganz klipp
und klar kommt und es war bei der
Wiedervereinigung so vielleicht gibt es
auch irgendwann eine Tendenz wo die
Leute sagen hier wir leisten und wir
wollen uns eine kurze Frage werden die
Steuern mit der nächsten Regierung eher
steigen oder werden sie eher sinken Kai
was glaubst Du sie werden eher steigen
was glauben sie werden steigen wegen der
billion die Corona gekostet hat sie
werden gleich bleiben weil ich glaube
Christian Lindner kann nicht die Ampel
machen inklusive steuerhöhungen
Christian Lindner kann die Ampel machen
wenn er dann der taff guy geblieben ist
gute im Lindner nein ich glaube dass
Moment Moment christian hat es 2017
keine als einziger Politiker von allen
mal gesagt ich regiere lieber nicht so
also Steuererhöhungen freue ich mich
Monolog anfange bleiben gleich es gibt
keine was sagen sie ich glaube es gibt
Steuererhöhungen aber nicht für alle
sondern für wenige und es ist ja ich
glaube sogar es gibt Steuerentlastung
für kleinere Einkommen aber
Steuererhöhung für größere Einkommen ich
glaube es gibt Steuerentlastung für
kleinere Einkommen es gibt keine
Steuersenkung für größere Einkommen und
ich glaube dass die Sozialbeiträge
steigen werden
kann
[Musik]